learn to build a weather app using
nextjs Tailwind CSS and typescript in
this Hands-On tutorial this is a great
project to understand how all these
Technologies work together you'll create
a responsive Dynamic app from scratch
with react components utar developed
this course in this today's video we are
going to build a simple weather app
using next gs14 and open Weather API
this is the fully functional weather app
and uh let's see the features of this uh
weather app so basically here we are
getting the today's date and temperature
and hourly wise temperature and weather
icon and weather data and here is the
weather description and uh there you
will find some additional details of our
weather like uh visibility humidity wind
speed air pressure sunrise and sunset
and after that you will find a 7 days
forecast data and here is the main
feature of our weather app here we will
also get a search SS suppose for example
if I will search for Delhi so now you
can see that we are getting a proper SS
for our location and if I will select
for any location and uh click on that
search button so we will get a data for
our that uh location so now you can see
that the weather report of our daily
location here we are getting the
temperature and description and some
additional details and uh obviously 7
days forecast data suppose I want to
search for Surat and if I will press
enter so this will search for that
location and here we are getting the
location name So currently which
location is applied and if you haven't
seen there uh suppose if I will search
for another location so we are also
getting a proper skeleton loading
components so on the meantime our when
our data is on the loading state so we
will get a proper skeleton loading if I
will refresh my page or we can also say
that on the first loading what we will
get so if I will refresh my
page so now you can see that we are
getting a proper loading State there
also and after that we will see our data
and I have also added a additional
feature for our weather app here is the
button and when I will hover over our
button here you can see that we are
getting a title like your current
location and when I will click on that
button so this will search for the
current location So currently my
location is made it so firstly this will
ask us uh permissions for our locations
for our location and after that uh this
will search for that location and
suppose if I will go to the another
location suppose I want to see a weather
report for Pune
location and uh see there we got the
location and again if I will click on
that current location button so now you
can see that we got a current location
data and uh currently I'm living on the
mered city so that's why we are getting
the city name here so I guess you are
very excited to build this uh weather
app before that let's see a additional
feature that is this application is also
fully responsive suppose if I go on the
mobile screen so you can see that on the
mobile screen this will look like this
and obviously we can check our data by
scrolling there like that and on the
desktop this will look like this so I
guess you are excited to build this
weather app so let's get
started so to build this weather app we
are going to use a next GS so first of
all we will go to our browser and search
for
nextjs so we will go on that first
website and uh here we will find the
installation command to install a next
CH so I will copy the command from there
and uh go to the place where I want to
install my nextg app so here I will
create a new folder and give that folder
name is weather app and after that go to
inside that folder and open a CMD on
that
location and after that paste your
command there and uh after pasting your
command add a do do there so with the
help of dot we don't have to give any
project name this will install our
project inside that
folder and after that this will ask us a
few questions like what do you like to
use type a script Tailwind CSS and etc
etc so what we will do we will just
press enter enter and install all the
default options so I'm just pressing
enter there uh for the es lint also yes
enter for the T CSS enter and uh this is
asking like would you like to use Source
directory so yes I want to use Source
directory and after that app router
obviously yes and uh for the input
allies
no now our uh next CS is installing so
this will take a little bit of time
maybe 1 minute or 2 minute so I will es
skip that part so now our next GS
project is successfully installed so
let's open our project in vs code so for
that we will type code dot there and
press enter so this will open a vs code
on that location so now we will uh run
our project and see the output so first
of all we'll open a terminal so I will
open a terminal with the help of control
J and after that on that terminal I will
write npm run
da so this will open my project on Local
Host 3001 but in your case this will
open your project in Local Host Port
3000 because on my port 3000 my previous
project is running so that's why this is
opening on Local Host Port
3001 so let's go to the browser and uh
search for local host for
3001 and here currently we are just
getting a default styling by nextjs so
let's again go to the code and uh from
here we will go to the source folder and
inside that Source folder we will go to
the page. TSX and inside that page. TSX
we will remove all the default code from
there like that and for now I'm just
printing
hello and uh we will also go to the
global. CSS file and from there we will
remove all the default stying from there
also and now let's save your code and
see the output So currently we are just
getting hello now let's see the final
output what we need to create so here
first of all we will create our Navar
and after that we will create other
components so let's go to your code
again and on the source folder we will
create another folder name components
and inside that components folder we
will create our components and inside
that component we will firstly create
our na bar. TSX file and inside that we
will create our naar component so I will
just type TS RFC so this will create a
format function for our component and
now here we will uh write a code for our
naar component so first of all let's
style our naar component so I will take
uh this div as a nav and inside that we
will pass the class names that is sadow
SM
sticky top zero left zero Z50 and bz
White so with the help of this sticky we
will get our naar always top so this
will stick on that position for always
and with the help of this top zero and
left zero we are giving the position for
our Nar and after that we will again
create another Dave inside our naar and
here we will give the class name for
this Dave and inside that class name we
will give the height of our nav bar is
80 pixel and uh width will be full and
uh this will be the flex justify between
and items Center and Max width will be 7
XL and padding X will be three and
obviously margin X will be Auto so with
the help of this margin X Auto what this
will do this will automatically Center
our container or anything on the x-axis
so that's why we are giving this MX Auto
and inside that Dave we will create a
one paragraph tag and on that paragraph
tag we will give the class name of this
that is flex items Center justify Center
Gap two and we don't need
border and uh while I'm adding a
paragraph you can see this in a second
and inside that paragraph we will add a
S2 styling for that S2 is text Gray and
text 3 XEL so if I will save my code and
first of all I need to import my naar
component in page so first of all I will
import it there like that and uh if you
will see the final output there so here
we are getting our background color uh a
little bit gray so for that uh we will
give the class name on our D tag and
inside that we will give these class
name that is flex and flex column and
after that we are giving a gap and BG
gray 100 so with the help of this BG
gray 100 we will get our background
color gray and we are also giving a
minimum height of screen and inside that
we are passing our na bar and uh if we
will see our output so now you can see
that currently we are getting our Navar
something like this so let's go to the
nabar
again and here we don't need this nabar
keyword and now let's save it again and
see so now you can see that currently
this is looking like this and now if you
will see there so for the logo we are
using icon so for the icon I'm using a
react icons so first of all we need to
install a react icons in our project so
we will go to the another Tab and search
for react
icons and uh we will go to that first
link and first of all we need to install
our react icons so here is the
installation code so I will copy the
installation code from there and uh come
to my code so I will open a new terminal
with the help of of control shift and
back Tex and after that I will paste my
installation command there and uh press
enter so this will install my react
icons and after that again we will go to
that react icons and uh now we need to
search for our icon so our icon is Sun
so I will just search for Sun and if you
will see the final output so here our
sun is looking like something this one
so we need to search for this icon
so here you can pick any icon that you
want but I already know the name of that
icon so I will just directly search for
the full name so our icon is this MD WB
Sunny so I will just click on that one
and here I will click on this so this
will copy icon in the form of component
and uh after that uh we need to go to
the code and uh paste our icon there
like that and again go to the browser
and uh click on on that import code so
this is the import code for our
icons and after that uh we will paste
our icon there now we have successfully
imported our icon but here we need to
style it additionally so here I will use
a class name for that and on that class
name we need to give a text size of 3 XL
and on the margin top will be one so I
need to give the margin top inside the
class name and after that we need to
give a color for our icon so we can give
the color for our icon easily with the
help of text property so I need to give
a color of text yellow
300 and uh when I will save my code and
see the output so our icon will look
like something
this and now we have created our logo or
icon something like this one now let's
create our search bar component so for
that I will create another section
and inside that section if you will see
there in the final output and after that
we have just a location icon and after
that we have a search bar
component so first of all let's import
these icons and after that uh we will
create our search bar component and
let's style this section also so this
will be the flex Gap 2 and items Center
and inside that we have our location
icon and for for the icons I will again
go to that website that is react icons
and uh search for location icon so here
we got our location icon so I will just
simply click on that one and uh after
that I need to click on that so this
will copy my icon in the form of code
and after that uh go to your code and
simply just paste and after that we need
to also import our icon so for that
again go to your browser and uh click on
that import code and uh paste your
import code there like that and uh let's
style your icon so so to style your icon
again we will use a class name and
inside that uh class name we will give
the text of
2XL and text will be gray
400 and on over we have a opacity off
and this icon we have also a cursor
pointer and let's see the output so here
we got our location icon like
this now let's add a another icon uh
this is also a location icon so for
again we'll go to the browser and uh see
we have already searched for location
icon but uh we need a different icon for
our location so for now I just know the
exact name for our location icon so I
will just search for that name directly
but you can choose any icon that you
want so in my case my icon name is this
one so I will just click on that one and
again do the same
process and here I will paste my icon
and uh now I need to import my icon so
you can also import your Icon by just uh
clicking on control space and after that
you will get a proper Solutions and
after that just press enter so this will
import your icon in your
location and now let's style this icon
also so for that we will again give the
class name and on that class name we
will give the we will give this size of
X 3XL and now let's see the output so
you will get your icon something like
this so now we need to make this proper
so here was the spelling mistake so
that's why we are not getting a proper
so I need to give this
Flex now this is
proper and now we have to also uh show
our location there so for that uh we
will use a paragraph tag there and we
have to also style our paragraph tag so
I will give the class name of this this
is text slate 900 and 80 means we 80
means I'm giving opacity of 80 and after
that I have given a text SM and on that
place I'm just writing a India and in
future we will change this location name
with our API data and for now let's save
and see the output so we got our
location there and now it's time to
create our uh search bar so for that
again we will create another section so
for that again I will create another div
and inside that we have our search bar
component so so here I will give this
search box there and uh we will create
our search boox component separately so
here I will give this file name
searchbox TSX and inside that we will
create our sample component with the
help of
tsfc and now we will style our search
component so if you will see there on my
search component so what I have done
something like uh when I will press
enter so this will also for our location
so for that we will use a form tag so
with the help of this form tag easily
handle a summit logic we don't have to
create any additional state or anything
we just have to use a form so for that I
will use a form tag there we don't have
to import a form from
anything this is form and now let's give
the styling for our form tag so this
will be the flx and relative items
Center justify Center and height will be
10 and inside that we will create our
input
tag and uh after our input tag we have
our icon so icon will be inside the
button so I will take a button tag and
inside that we have our search icon so
again for the search icon we will go to
that react icons and search for search
so we need to search for search and here
we need to search for exactly this
search icon in a small letters so this
is our search icon so again we have to
do the same process just need to click
on that icon and uh click on that
component so this will copy that
component and come to your code and
paste it there now import your icon so
to import again come to your browser and
uh click on that import code so this
will copy the import code from there
and now just paste your import code
there so your icon is successfully
imported so first of
all uh let's import our uh search bar
component in our nabar on that
place
and let's import it like that and see
the final output so here we are getting
a error because I guess I haven't saved
my search bar component so let's save
this and now see we are not getting any
error so here is our input and search
icon so let's make it side by side our
code and output so we can see easily
what's going on there so now let's style
our input tag so first of all let's give
a placeholder and on that placeholder we
will just simply give a search search
location like that and uh so yeah we got
our placeholder there and after that uh
let's give a class name so on that class
name we will give a padding X of four
padding y of two and uh width will be
230 pixel and uh we are also giving a
border and Border will be gray color
that is border gray 300 and uh we are
also giving a rounded left MD we are
just only giving a rounded on the left
hand side and on the focus outline will
be none and on the focus we are changing
the background color from Gray to Blue
that is uh blue 500 and the height will
be full so we are giving the height full
there but here we are giving the height
10 so this will apply the height of that
search boox component according to this
and when I will save my code so we got
our input style something like
this now uh let's style our button also
so again uh here we will use a class
name and on that class name we will pass
a padding X of 4 padding y of 9 AIS BG
will be blue 500 text white rounded and
uh if you will notice there so here we
are passing a rounded right and here we
are passing a rounded left so on this
one we are just giving a rounded left
and on that button we are giving a
rounded right so that this will look
like this are joining together and after
that we are giving again on Focus
outline will be none and on who we are
giving a BG blue
600 and uh we don't need this wh space
wh space no app and height will be full
now you can see that our button will
look like this and we have also added a
h effect there and there also now it's
time to add a props for our search
component so so here uh first of all we
need a value prop and on change prop and
uh on submit prop like when the user
submit or click on that button so for
that we will use on submit
prop and our value will be string type
and uh so what will be the type of our
on change so for that we need to write
on change there and after that we need
to H over that on change so here you can
see that
they have given the type for our on
change so we just have to Simply copy
our type from there so I will just copy
from there and paste it there simply
like that and for on submit
also again I will hover over there and
here you can see that they have given
the type so I will just copy it from
there and paste it there and uh if you
will see there carefully so they are
just simply using a a change event
handler there and after that HTML input
element and on that one react do form
event handler and HTML form
element and uh after that here we need
to pass uh props like that and uh we
need to pass the values of our props
there so here we need to write props dot
on submit for submit and for on change
which need to write props do uh onchange
like that and for the value we will
write value there and props do
value and uh here we need additional
property that is class name
prop so I will just copy the class name
from there and uh the type of our class
name will be the string and uh this will
be the conditional so maybe sometimes we
need a class name or maybe sometime we
don't don't need a class name so that's
why we are passing our class name with
the help of this question mark
operator and let's save this but here we
have defined the class name on the props
but we are not using there so to use
this we have to pass our class name on
that place on that parent form class
name so for that we will use a
additional function that is called CN
function so I have already created a
video on that topic how to use or how to
create a CN function I will give that
video link on my description below but
uh don't worry if you don't know about
CN function I will also explain a CN
function in this video so now let's
create a CN utility function so for that
we will come to the source folder and
inside that Source folder we will create
a utils folder and inside that utils
folder we need to create a CN function
so here first of all we will create a CN
file with the help of of cn. TS and uh
we need to export our CN function so
first of all I will write export
function
CN and like this and uh after that we
need to return our logic from there so
to create our CN function we need to
install our two libraries so first one
is a Tailwind merge and second one is a
clsx we will use a Tailwind merge to
merge our Tailwind classes and uh we
will use a CSX package to pass a
conditional classes first of all let's
install these two
packages and after installing these two
packages first of all we will import a
delin merge there and inside that
Tailwind merge we will pass our clsx
package there and if I will hover over
that so you can see that what uh we can
pass inside that clsx so I will just
copy it from there and uh whatever we
need inside that clsx we also need the
inputs on that CN function also so I
will paste it there and uh we need to
import this class value type so I will
just press control space so this will
show me the SS from where I need to
import so let's just press enter or
click on that s so this will import that
uh class value type from clsx and let's
copy this inputs and pass inside that
clsx now we have uh successfully created
our CN
function now let's copy this CN function
and uh come to your search box component
and now what you need to do cut these
classes and put a curly bracket there
and inside that Curly bracket we will
use our CN function and add a
parenthesis there and pass your default
classes
and after that we need to pass
additional classes with the help of this
class name so we will write it like that
props do class name so if anyone will
pass additional class names there so
this will add our classes in that place
but in some cases if someone try to pass
uh same class for example we have
already applied a height 10 and I'm
trying to pass a additional height for
example height 20 so this will only
overwrite that height and whatever we
pass in last this class name will apply
now here we have completed our search
boox
component and let's see the output so
there's nothing changed in the
output now we will see which API we are
using and how we can fetch the data from
that API and everything so for that we
will go to the browser and you have to
go to the open weather map.org and there
here first of all you have to login and
uh if you haven't created your account
on open weather so first of all you have
to create an account for your open
weather and after that login on that
open weather and after that click on
that your username so there and after
that you have to click on my
apis and uh after that click on that and
here I have created two API keys and uh
if you want to create your new API key
just give the name there and click on
generate so this will create a new API
key for you and after that copy your API
key which you want to use and there we
will create a new file that is env.
local and inside that we will paste our
API key so for that I will give that
name next public weather Key and after
that I will paste my API key there so
currently what I'm doing I'm just
pasting my API key there and after that
I can use it globally anywhere I want
and we are storing our API key in EnV
file so that uh our API is so that our
API is not exposed publicly and now
let's come to the main page and first of
all we will test our API so this is our
API and here we have to replace our API
key with our key so for now I'm so for
now just let's remove this one and on
the place of this I will copy my API key
from there and paste it there and on the
place of place I'm just writing a uh
like punee I want to see the weather
report for Pune location and let's copy
your API and uh go to your browser and
just paste it there like that so now you
can see that currently we are getting
all the weather data all information of
punee location here you can see that if
I will open on a different browser here
I've installed an extension so that's
why this is looking uh like this one and
here now you can see that we are getting
a data for our weather and uh on that
here we are also getting the country and
location name and coordinates and
population all of and like sunrise and
sunset so what we need to do first of
all we need to create a type for our
data so what I will do here on my API
key and uh in that one I am passing a 56
so this will return us a uh maximum 56
uh like lists of data we are getting a
56 weather reports data with 3 hours of
difference for example if you will see
there so currently on this list so if
you will see the time for that data
currently there now you can see that
this is
12:00 but on that second one we are
getting the time for that like 15 so on
that data we are getting a 3 hours of
difference so what I will do here for
now I'm just uh getting a two
data so now you can see that currently
we are getting a very less data so what
I will do I will copy all this data from
there and go to the chat GTP and what I
will do I need to create a type for our
data so I will just paste this data
there and tell that chat GTP to create a
type for that
data like that and whenever press
enter so now you can see that this
created a type for our data so what we
need to do we just have to Simply copy
this type from there and uh come to our
code and we just have to paste it simply
there so we have uh successfully created
our types for our data and now we will
see how we can fetch our data so to
fetch our data we are going to use a
react query so to use a react query
first of all I will go to the browser
and search for react query and uh here
we will get the official TCH query react
query website so we will go to that
website and uh we will click on that
read the docs and first of all we have
to install that react query so I will
copy the installation so I will copy the
installation command from there and come
to my code and firstly let's install the
react query like that and now again come
to that browser and click on that
overview here they have given the proper
example how we can use a react query so
first of all we have to wrap up our main
container with this query client
provider so in our case layout. ESX is
the main route of every file or our main
or every project so what we will do we
will first of all we will import query
client and query client provider on that
place so I will copy it from there and
paste it
there and uh what we need to do we need
to copy this one and wrap up our body
with this query client provider and we
have to also use this query client so I
will copy this one also from there and
paste it there like that so now our
error is gone
and when I will save my code and uh see
the output so now you can see that we
are getting error because we are using a
create context and uh create context
only works in client component and here
this component is or this file is a
server component so what we need to do
we need to convert uh this page in a
client component so for that I will use
a use client like that and save my file
and and uh now we are getting another
error like uh you are attempting to
export a metadata from component marked
and basically this is saying that uh we
have written a metadata and we can only
use a metadata on the use server
components so for now we don't need a
metadata so I will comment it
there and this one also so now you can
see that we are not getting any error
and now our next step is to gain see
there so on that example they are using
API like that so I will copy this code
from there and uh come to my code and we
have to go to the page file and here I
will paste that
code and let's also import a use Query
from react query and after that replace
your API so I will copy this API from
there and replace it with this one like
that and uh we have to use the async
function because we are fetching the
data from the API or basically a weather
API so maybe this will take a few
seconds or delay so that's why we will
use a async function there so to use a
async
function here we will write a
async like that and inside that async we
will fetch our data with the help of
exos so let's see how we can use exos
with react query so first of all we will
install a exos so I will install exos
with the help of npmi exos like that and
if you're using a exos then we don't
need to use a Fetch and we also don't
need to convert this into a Jon with the
help of exos this will handle it
automatically so let's see how we can do
that so inside that first of all we will
uh store this in a variable so I will
make this data or here we are using uh
async so that's why we need to write uh
a wait keyword and after that exos do
getet inside that get we have to pass
our URL or API link that we have to
fetch so I will paste it there and we
have to pass it with the help of this
Str string like that
and after that we have to return a data
from there like this and now we have to
give the type for our weather so the
type for our weather is weather data and
this will be like that and now if we
will check our data so I will copy this
data from there and let's console log
the data so here I will write
console.log and this is the data and
let's see our data there so here we are
getting error here because again here we
are again using a create context in our
page and we haven't defined our page as
a use client so we have to use a use
client there so here I will write a use
client like
that and now our error is gone and if we
will see our
output so let's see the data so here now
you can see that we got our data
properly there that uh we need now what
we need to do we need to replace our API
with that EnV API key so I will remove
this API from there and here we need to
use a btic and uh like
that and on that back Tex first we need
to pass our API key like uh process. EnV
and after that go to your EnV file and
copy the variable name from there and
come to your code come to your code
again and pass your variable there like
that and if I will save it again and see
the output and let's
refresh so now you can see that we got
our data again and uh why we need to
type for data suppose if I want to
additional data so I just just have to
press Dot and now you can see that I'm
getting an automatic Su like I want to
see the city so I will just simply write
city. country Dot and uh city. country
and let's save and see the output so now
you can see that I'm getting a in so in
means India and let's see something else
so uh let's see data do City do name so
now you can see that we got our city
name that is
punee and now we don't need this code so
let's remove this one now let's also
create our loading full page loading
component when our data firstly load so
how it will look on the loading state so
for that we will create a div and inside
that div we will pass these class names
that is flex items Center minimum height
will be screen justify
Center and uh inside that we will pass
our loading text so this will be like
that and uh inside that we have to pass
our class names class name that is
animate bounce and if I will save my
code and see the output so now you can
see that this will look like this now
let's create these UI so here I will
create a main tag and inside that main
tag we will give the class names and the
class name will be padding X3 and and uh
Max width will be 7 XL and MX will be
Auto and uh this will be flex and flex
column and GAP will be N9 and width will
be full and I'm giving a padding of 10
and padding top will be four and inside
that div inside that div we have two
sections if you will see the final
output so first section is like today
data so from this container to this
container we have a 2-day data and after
that we have a 7 days forecast data so
for that uh we will create a section
tag and we have a two section tag so
first section tag will be today data
7-day forecast data so first of all
let's create a today data so here inside
that we will take another div and this
div denotes to this container so this
will contain this date and and this data
so if you will see there so inside that
we have also a two div or two container
so here I will take uh like first one is
a S2 and after that uh so let's first of
all style this S2 div so inside that S2
div we have a flex and uh gap of one
text will be 2 XEL and items Center so
why I'm taking this uh Flex because if
you will see there so firstly we are
getting a day and after that we are
getting a data so these two will be in a
separate div or container so that's why
I'm taking like this so for that uh take
a paragraph tag there and now first of
all we have to show a day so if you will
see the data there that uh we are
getting from our API so let's uh go to
there and just write data there so now
you can see there we are getting our
lists and inside that list we are
getting our date but uh with the help of
date we need a but with the help of date
we need a day and uh let me tell you
another thing uh in that array we are
not getting any forecast data from the
back end uh we are just only getting the
data by hourly wise hourly wise means we
are getting all these list uh
differentiate with 3 hours for example
they are getting uh weather of like
12:00 and after that 300 p.m. and after
that
6:00 likewise we are getting all these
data so we have to make some logic and
uh differentiate with the differentiate
with 7 days forecast data so here first
of all if you will see on the UI on that
place we need to show a day and date of
first list of data so for that we will
separate our first list data so for that
I will create a variable uh like uh
First Data and inside that first data we
have a data do list and we need a first
list like that and let's check that date
so from that date we are not getting a
day in the form of like Monday Tuesday
Wednesday so what we need to do we need
to convert this date into a day so for
that we will use another Library that's
name is date FNS so let's go to the
browser and uh search for date
FNS so there you will get that npm
website and go to
there so now you can see the use case of
that date FNS but don't worry I will
also show you the use case of this
Library so first of all copy this
installation code and uh come to your
code and install this library and after
installing our library we have to show a
day on that place so what I need to do I
need to use a format from date FNS so I
will import it first like that and after
that uh we have to use par ISO and we
have to also import uh import this par
ISO from date FNS date FNS like that and
uh inside that par ISO we have to pass
our data so our data is First Data do
date like that and maybe we don't get
sometime our data so for that case we
will pass this empty string because we
must have to pass something there
otherwise this will show us a error and
after that put a comma and after that we
have to pass a second parameter of
format like uh which type of format we
want so to show a day we have to pass a
e e four times like that so here we are
still getting error so I've tried so
many things why I'm getting error so I
find out like on that latest version
this is not working so we have to use a
previous version so for that I will
again go to that library and uh I will
click on that versions and I will use
that 2.3 version so when you will click
on that one so here on the right hand
side you will get that installation
command for that 2.30 version so I will
click on that one and uh open a terminal
here and install this
version so we have successfully
installed this version now our error is
gone so you can see that our a is gone
and our code is working fine and if I
will save this one and uh see the
output so now you can see that here we
are getting a
Tuesday and uh let's see there now we
need a date so for the date uh we will
again go to the code and here we need
another paragraph and inside that
paragraph We will pass our code like
that we will use again same as it is
like format and inside that we will use
par ISO and uh we are passing that date
and after that uh we need a format like
dd. mm do after that YY y so when I will
save this one so now you can see that we
got our date like this
format
and let's also give the class name
there and I will give this text LG and
this text will be 2XL and this will be
LG and when I will save this so now this
will look like this now let's create
this component or this container so if
you will see there so here one thing is
common so here for this one I have
created a common component and uh now
I'm using a same component in this one
this one this one and and this one also
so what we will do we will create a
separate component with the name of
container and after that we will use
this in that place so let's go to the
code again and on our components folder
we will create a new file with
container. TSX again let's type tsfc so
this will create a normal format
function for our component and here
let's style our Dave so by default we
will pass with full and BG will be white
and Border rounded Excel and uh we will
also pass
flex and uh padding y will be four and
Shadow will be SM and uh now what we
need to do we need to pass a children
there and we also need a like if user
want to pass a extra classes so they
will pass easily so before that first of
all we will use a div props like if the
user maybe pass like any on click or any
something so what we will do we will
pass all these props there so let's see
how we can do that so for that here we
will just simply write props and what
will be the type of that props this will
be the react. HTML props div element so
why div element because here we are
using a div so that's why we need to
pass a stml div element there and after
that here we will use a triple dot or we
can also say that rest operator and on
that place we will pass our uh props
like that so with the help of this props
we will get all these possible props on
that place and now we also don't need
this container and extra div we can just
simply autoc close so this will also
like uh accept or give us a child props
and now we need to pass extra classes if
the user want to pass a extra class name
so I will cut this class name and use a
curly bracket there and here we need a
CN function again and on that one we
need to pass our default classes and
inside that default classes we will use
props do class name like this and here
we have successfully created our
container component and we don't need
this type props so let's remove this and
copy this container from there and uh
now we need a container in that place so
I will import it there like that so for
that I will use a control space and
press enter so this will import the
container so on that container what we
need we need this temperature and like
feels like and this minimum and maximum
temperature so here first of all let's
give the class name there because we
want to pass extra classes so here I'll
just write simply class name and now you
can see that we are getting all the
possible props for our da with the help
of uh this rest operator that we are
using and inside that class name we have
already passed a flex so we don't need
to give a flex and after that we need a
gap and we need a padding X of six and
items will be Center so why I'm doing
this one because if you will see there
here we have a three elements first one
is a temperature and uh this is Fields
like temperature and after that uh we
have a minimum and maximum so this will
be in the form of column and if we will
go to there again so on our left hand
side we have our temperature and on our
right hand side we have our weather icon
and uh time and temperature so first of
all we will uh create this one and after
that uh we'll create this one so for our
temperature let's give a div and uh
inside that div we need this class name
that is flex Flex column padding X4 and
after that we need a temperature so if I
will console log there and uh see the
data so let's go to the our data so here
on our main but here is one problem that
uh we are not getting our temperature in
Celsius
we are getting our temperature in Kelvin
so what we will do we will create a
function that will convert our Kelvin
data to a Celsius so let's go to the
code again and uh on our utils we will
create a new file and give that file
name to convert Kelvin to celsius. TS
and we need to export this function and
we need to use this code so here we are
accepting a Kelvin temperature and after
that uh we are from that Kelvin
temperature we are minusing
273.15 and after that we are using a
math do floor to remove all the decimal
parts and uh keep the integers maybe you
don't know how to make this function
like convert Kelvin to Celsius so what I
have done there I have just simply go to
the chat GTP and uh tell that J GTP like
I'm getting the temperature data and I
need that data into the form of Celsius
so chat GTP understood and uh he just
simply create a function for me so just
I'm just using their function and this
works perfectly fine so let's come to
the page again and here what uh we will
do here we will pass this function there
and uh we also need to import this
function and inside that function we
need to pass our first data Dot main do
temperature like that and here we are
also getting an error because this
function is not conditional and uh maybe
from our data sometimes or maybe this is
loading uh maybe this is on the loading
state so we must have to pass something
there so for that we will use a double
question mark so it means like uh
suppose on the left hand side our data
is not coming so this will pass this
data so for now I'm just passing this
one but you can also do one thing you
can pass a default temperature there so
in that case what I will do I will just
copy that temperature from there and uh
pass it there like that and now we need
a this temperature text that is uh
something circle like that and when I
will save and see the output so we are
getting an error so let's see why we are
getting error so I guess because I
haven't saved this code now I I have
saved all of this file with the help of
control K you can see that I have
pressed control K there on my uh this
Bottom bar I have pressed save so with
the help of this all of my pages are
saved now see there here we are getting
a 23 degree and also maybe you will not
get this uh degrees text so you just
have to Simply go to the Google and find
for degree so you will get it from there
or anywhere from there any any anywhere
from the Google just copy it from there
and uh use it on the on your code and
now what we need to do we need to add
this Fields like and this and this will
be inside the span tag and the class for
this span tag is will be the text will
be
5xl and this will be inside that span
tag and now let's create another
paragraph tag and inside that paragraph
tag uh we need to pass this class name
that will be text extra small and Space
X will be one so Space X means this will
give a space of four pixel and after
that I'm using a white space no app so
with the help of this white space no W
this will not break the line and uh
inside that uh we will use text that is
called Wheels like and after that we
have to pass our Fields like temperature
like this one and let's see the output
so we will get our output something like
this one and after that paragraph We
have to take another paragraph tag and
inside that paragraph tag we have to
pass our minimum and maximum temperature
so first of all let's give the class
name for this paragraph tag so this will
be the text extra small and Space X will
be two and inside that we will use a
span tag now we have to pass our minimum
temperature and maximum temperature like
this one so I'm again using that
function and on that I'm just passing a
First Data do
mean. temp Min so we will easily get
this data from our API suppose if I will
press a back button so now you can see
that I'm easily getting also a proper SS
there and uh after that we have to put
this degree sign and this Arrow text so
you will easily get that arot text from
Google and now let's save and see the
output so now you can see that we are
properly getting our minimum and maximum
temperature and now if you will see
there so we are not getting any space
between this date and this container so
let's give the space so for that here uh
we will add the
space on that place on the section and
on that Dave that uh will contain our H2
that will contain our H2 and uh this
container so let's also give the space
there so here we will give the space of
space y of two and let's see the output
so here we got our space now let's
create this so for that come to the code
and here and after that we have our time
and uh weather icon right so what we
will do for that so for that again
create a new div and inside that div we
will add a class name so let's add these
class names this is flex and we need a
gap of 10 and on the SM screens we have
a gap of
16 so uh by default on the mobile
screens we will Gap we have the gap of
10 so 10 means 40 pixel and uh when this
will come to the SM screens so we will
have have the gap of 64 pixels and what
we are doing if there is Overflow or
more data so for that we are writing a
overflow X Auto so with the help of this
we will get our scroll bar and after
that we are giving a width full and
justify between and padding right and
you know what is the mean of justify
between with the help of justify with
WIS and after that here comes our main
part we need to map our data so here uh
we are getting our data from our API
from there so I will uh write data there
so this will be the data and after that
we have to map our list so so for so
after that we will write data. list do
map and uh parenthesis inside that Arrow
function inside that Arrow function we
have to create our main part uh we have
to show show our main like weather icon
and temperature so for that uh let's
create another div there and uh first of
all let's pass a key otherwise this will
uh give us a error and here first of all
we are getting a d means data and second
parameter is a index and inside that key
we will pass a
i and after that let's give a class name
for that div so for the class name we
will use a flex and flex column so we
are using a flex column because we have
to show our data in the form of columns
So currently we are working on that part
so first of all we will show the time
after that weather image and after that
obviously temperature and uh after that
we are giving a gap items Center or text
small or font semi Bol and now first of
all we have to show our time so for that
again we will use a paragraph tag and uh
inside that paragraph tag will pass our
time so for the time first of all we
will use a format from our date FNS
Library so for that I will write a
format and inside that format first of
all we have to pass so again we have to
use a parse ISO and uh now we have to
pass our time so time will be T do DT
text so with the help of this we will
get the exact date from our data and
after that we have to pass a format of
our data so here I will write H do mm
and a so with the help of a we will also
get AM or PM and now let's save and uh
see the output so yeah currently you can
see that we are getting the time of 300
p.m. 600 p.m. or like 12:00 a.m. like
that so if you will see there so
currently this is getting in a two lines
but uh what we need we need in a single
line
so for that we will pass a class name
that is called wh space no
app and let's save this and uh see the
output so yeah we got our data in a
single line and now let's add a weather
icon so before that first of all let's
add a temperature and after that I will
show you how we can add a weather icon
so for our temperature let's again take
a paragraph tag and pass our temperature
like that like we have done before D do
mean and temp means temperature and uh
if we are not getting any temperature so
by default we will pass zero and after
that uh this is the degree text and
let's save this so we will got our time
and temperature now we have to show our
weather icon so for the weather icon
here we have to create another separate
component and uh so let's see how how we
can create our weather icon component so
on that uh components folder here I will
create a new file with the name of
weather icon. TSX and let's write tsfc
to create a sample format and inside
that we have to use a image tag so I
will import image from next image and
here we have to remove scarly
bracket and after that we have to pass
our Source there so what will be the
source of our image so I for this I have
another API of open weather so let's go
to your browser and see this one so now
you can see that with the help of this
API we will get our weather icons just
we need to replace this like 01 D so if
I will pass
02d so we will get a different icons
with the help of this so we will use
this link so in the place of source we
will pass our uh API Source like that
and uh after that let's style our image
so here uh let's pass uh height and
width for image so width will be 100 and
height will be 100 and let's also pass
alt so on the alt we will pass a weather
icon and we have to also pass a class
name so for the class name I will use a
absolute there and height will be full
and width will be full and uh here on
that div let's use a CN function suppose
in that case if we need uh if we need to
pass any extra class names so again we
will use a CN utility function there and
inside that uh we will pass our default
classes so our default classes is
relative and inside that relative we
have to pass a
H2 H20 so h0 20 means height will be 20
and width will be 20 so here our height
and width will be full and what is the
mean of this height and width so with
the help of this height and width this
will load that much of our image on that
quality means uh this will load 100
pixel width of height and 100 pixel of
width this will load and after that we
are customizing our height from there so
mainly this height will apply and uh
with the help of this we are getting
that much of quality image and now we
have to pass our icon name props there
but here we also need uh all of our
props there so in some case if we need
to pass any extra property there so on
that case what we will do here uh we
will write props and after that what we
have done for our container component so
I will go to The Container component and
I will copy this props from there and
and paste it there like that and now we
need additional prop that is called uh
icon name so that I am passing there so
I will pass it there like that and this
will be the type of string so I will
write it like that and we need a single
end operator now this is fine and on the
place of Icon we have to use a props do
icon like that and here uh we need all
of our props so here I will write uh
props like that so with the help of this
I am passing all of our props on that da
now we have successfully completed our
weather icon component so let's save
this one and copy this component and
come to our page and we need our uh
weather icon component on that place so
I will paste it there and just simply
import my weather icon component
there and uh we need to pass a icon name
so if you will come to that data so I
will press uh F12 and let's see the data
and inside that data go to the weather
and inside that uh weather you can see
that we are getting our icon we are
getting a value of
04n so this is the icon name that we
need to pass in our icon
component so here I will write it like
uh D do weather and on that weather we
need to access a first
property and after that we need to pass
a icon like that and let's save this and
see the
output so here we are getting a error
because here we are using a open Weather
image API so we need to configure this
in an xgs so to configure this so first
of all let's click on this one
and uh after that uh copy all of this
code and uh come to your code and go to
the next config file so I'm just
pressing a contrl p and finding a
finding with the help of this next
config and replace all of your code with
this code now what you need to do come
to your output again and uh see there
that's what error I'm getting so this is
saying that I have I haven't configured
that host name so just let's copy this
host name from there and replace it with
example host name and uh we don't need
this path name and port and let's save
all of our files and reload this
page now you can see that our error is
gone and uh we got our images with the
help of our API and here one thing also
like if you will see there so currently
I'm getting all of our images same uh
because from our API we are getting uh
these images but on that weather image
API on the place of D if I will write n
so now you can see that I'm getting a
night image so what we need to do we
need to create a function to like uh to
separate our data like uh currently we
are passing a night image or uh Day
image so here I will create another
function like get day or night icon and
on that icon we will pass our current
date and time and our icon name so what
this will return us so if it is before
6:00 a.m. time so this will return a
night icon and after 600 a.m. this will
return a day icons so let's go to the
code
again and on our utils we will create
another function so here I will come to
the utils folder and create another
function that is called day or night
icon. TSX sorry dots yes and inside that
uh we will use this function so this
function will accept our icon name and
uh date and time in the form of string
so here what we are doing we are just
checking there like uh if our time is
less than 6 less than or equals to 6
a.m. and if our time is greater than
equals to 6 so basically what's we are
doing we are checking our like it's time
between our 600 a.m. or 6:00 a.m. to 600
p.m. so this means our daytime so here
we checking like it's the time if this
is the day time so we are returning a
day otherwise we are returning a and
there so this function I have also
created with the help of chat GTP so I
will just copy this function and uh come
to that code again so for now just copy
this one and comment this above and here
first of all let's use this get uh deite
icon import this function and inside
that let's pass a d dot weather and uh
first of all we are passing our icon so
dot icon like that and second parameter
will be our date so for that put a comma
there D do DT txt like that and let's
save this and uh see our output so on
that night and day we are getting a same
icon because for n night and day we have
a same icon so for example if I check
for the icon so now you can see there we
are getting our same icon so that's why
here we are also on our output we
getting the same icon and let's see the
final output
again so here basically we have done our
main parts this today's date and
temperature now let's create a UI for
our 7 days forecast data so now we will
create uh this UI so let's again come to
your
code and uh come to the page. ESX file
and there we have created another
section for our 7 days forecast data so
inside that first of all we have a
paragraph tag and inside that paragraph
tag we have to write 7day
forecast so this will be like this and
uh let's also style this
paragraph so this will be the class name
of text 2XL and we have to also give the
class name for our section tag so on
that section tag we will give the class
name of flex and width will be full and
flex column Gap will be four now comes
our main part if you will see the main
app so inside that uh there is a same
component that is repeating seven times
so what we will do first of all we will
create this component so let's come to
the code again and uh give this
component name called forecast weather
detail and uh now let's come to the
components folder and inside that we
will create that file that is called
forecast feather detail. TSX and now we
will write TS
RFC to create our sample component and
now inside that uh we will create
our
forecast now we will create our forecast
detail component so if you will see the
final output so this component is wrap
up with our container component so first
of all we will use a container there so
I will write container and uh we have
successfully imported our container
component and inside that container
component but before we make this
weather forecast I forgot one thing we
have to also create this section so
first of all let's create this section
and on that section we have to show a
description there and uh extra details
on that place so let's come to the code
again and we need to go to the page and
after that we have to create another
Dave and inside that Dave we have our
two containers so first of all let's
give the class name for that da uh that
will be the flags and uh Gap will be
four and inside that we have our two
containers so first one will be our left
and second one is our right
so I'm just commenting it there and
after that uh let's import our container
there and inside that let's pass a class
name so we will use this class name that
is width will be fit according to our
content this will uh resize our width
and after that we are just passing a
justify Center Flex column and ping X
will be four and items Center and uh
inside that we have to show a weather
description so first first of all we
will take a paragraph and after that we
have to show a weather icon so what we
have done there for our weather icon so
I will just copy this one and uh simply
paste it on that place but uh here on
the place of data we have to write a
First Data and on that place also we
have to replace D with the help with
First Data and this is giving us a error
like uh this may be undefined so what we
will do we will use this double question
mark and here we will pass a empty
string and we will do the same for this
one also so this means in some case if
we don't get a data so this will pass a
empty string there and uh on the place
of paragraph We have to show a weather
description so we will what we will do
we will uh show a first so we will show
a description of our first data so here
I will again use use a First Data dot
weather and on that weather we have to
select first element and uh we have to
show a description of our first element
like that and if we will see the output
so this will look like this one and now
we have to style our paragraph so here I
will give this here I will give this
capitalize and text Center like this one
so this will look like something this
now let's create uh this right da so for
the right da we will again use another
container so again I will just write a
container like that and inside that
container we have to change our
background color so for that let's use a
class name and we have to use a yellow
color so I will pass a BG yellow 300
like that and this will have the opacity
of 80 and after that padding X will be
six and uh Gap will be four justify
between and overflow X Auto and when I
will save this So currently we will just
get this output now what uh we need to
do we need to create a separate
components to show our weather
details and if you will see there these
components and these components are the
same so what I will do I will create a
same component for this one and uh after
that we will use this component on that
place also so now we will create a
weather details component so let's go to
the components folder again and here we
will create a weather details. TSX file
and inside that uh here uh we will write
TS RFC now let's create our weather
details component so on that weather
details component we won't use any div
because we are styling it from parent
container so let's again come to the
weather details and for our weather
details component we have to create
another component that is called single
weather detail so here we will create a
single weather detail component so here
I will write function single weather
detail and let's also create a type for
our single weather detail props and here
we will write a function like that and
uh we will pass our props and props will
we have this type like
that and here we need a return and on
that return we will currently we are
creating uh this div that D will contain
this description or after that image and
uh this value data so that's why I have
uh taken here three props that is
information icon value so first of all
let's create a parent T there on that
parent Dave we will give the styling of
flex Flex call justify between Gap two
items Center and text extra small and uh
font semi-old and text PL and I'm
passing a text PL with 80%
opacity and inside that we need another
paragraph that will contain information
so I will use it like that class name
and uh I'm using a white space no WP so
with the help of this white space no
wrap this text will not break into a
separate line this will show our data in
a single line and here uh we have to do
like props do
information and uh now I have to show
icon on that
place so here I will also pass icon from
our props so I'm just writing it like
that and here we will use a props do
icon for the icons we will use a react
icons so that's why I'm passing there
text 3XL so this will apply all of our
icon that we will pass on that
component and uh now we have to show a
value so for the value we will use a
props do value like that now we have uh
successfully completed our single
weather detail
component now what we need to do we have
to just simply use that uh single we
component on that place and uh we have
to pass all these props so on the first
prop we have icon and on the second one
information and on the third one we have
a value so if you will see there this
data will be always same like visibility
humidity wind speed air pressure or
Sunrise I mean that information and icon
will be always same for like you can see
there I'm getting the same information
there and for this one this one same
same same same like humidity humidity
wind speed wind speed so I will pass
these data manually and uh we have to
pass these values in our
props so how we can do that so if you
will see there first of all we need a i
image and like and likewise here we are
using a drop image and after that wind
image and likewise here we are using a m
image so for our I we will use this icon
Lu I so for the I we will use this Lu e
e icon and we and we will import this
icon from react icons so I already know
what is the icon name but uh you can
simply go to the react icons and uh
search for your icon suppose if you want
to search for I icon so just simply go
there and search for I like that then
you will get uh your icon then you just
have to click on that icon and and uh
click on that component then you will
automatically get copied your code but
in that case I already know the icon
name so I will just import import my
icon so to import my icon I will just
simply import it from react icons like
that and here I have to import it from
Lu like this one and now we have to
create a props for this
one like uh see the final output so we
have to create our props for visibility
humidity wind speed like that so what we
will do we will create our props like
this and uh this so this component will
have these props like visibility
humidity wind speed air pressure sunrise
and sunset let's copy this props type
from there and uh paste it there and now
let's write it props there and here we
have to write
props do
visibility and likewise and likewise we
have to also do it for like humidity so
I will just copy this one and uh change
the name from visibility to humidity and
I have to also change the icon so I
already know the icon name so the icon
is fi droplet and I have to also import
that icon so I will import my icon like
this one and likewise I have to import
all of our icons and uh all these
possible props so I will just copy and
paste from my previous code and here
what we will do we will pass some
default values if like suppose if we are
not passing any values from the API so
for that what we will do here we will
create another variable and on that
variable we will destructure all of our
props from our props and uh we will pass
our default values and after that we
will pass our values
on that component like that and let's
copy this weather details component from
there and now we have to use this
weather detail component on that
place and let's also import our weather
detail component here so here we have to
pass all of our props so first is air
pressure so for the air pressure if we
will go to our data so let's press F
Well there and uh see the data so on the
main you will find that pressure so this
is the air pressure so we have to just
show it exactly like that so first of
all we have to show a visibility so
let's come to the visibility so when you
will click on that City so on that list
you will get the visibility there so it
doesn't matter what uh you will pass on
that component first this will apply all
these in that manner that uh here we are
passing now on that firstly let's pass
uh visibility so for the
visibility what we need to do so for all
these data we have to select first data
and uh from that first data we have to
show all these additional data so here
if you will see in our data so we are
getting our data in a meters and if you
will see the final output so we have to
convert uh this data into a kilometers
so for that again we will create another
uh utility function that is meters to
kilometers so let's go to the utility
fun FES and here we will write me. 2 km
do DS and inside that we will create
this function that is called meters to
kilometers and this will accept uh
visibility in meters and after that this
will convert this into a kilometers and
I have also created this function from
CH GTP so if you are stuck in any place
so you can just simply ask to the chat
GTP like I want to create this function
or component or anything
so let's just copy this one and uh we
have to use this on that place so let's
pass this function there and import our
meters and now we have to use a first uh
data inside that first data we have to
pass a visibility and in some case if
our visibility is not coming so we will
pass our default visibility that is
10,000 that we are getting from our data
by default and let let's also pass a air
pressure so for the air pressure first
of all let's use a back tix there and
inside that back tix we will use a
dollar symbol and inside that we will
pass our first data do main do pressure
so we will get our pressure and after
that we have to write a
HPA and when I will save and see the
output so here we are getting error so I
guess I have imported components two
times so let's check there so there is
something wrong in weather details
component so let's check it there so
here I have created this component on
that place and I'm just importing it so
let's remove it from there and now you
can see that our error is gone and uh we
are now getting another different error
so I guess I haven't save this meters to
kilomet function so let's uh save all of
our files so now you can see that our
error is gone and we are getting our
data so here you can see that first of
all we are getting our visibility and uh
this 108 HPA pressure and we are also
getting our others data so we are
getting our others data because if you
will see on that here we have passed our
default values for our props so that's
why we are getting our default values
there now let's go to the code again and
pass other datas so other data will be
humidity so for the humidity again we
will do the same here we will use a back
tiex curly bracket and dollar symbol
inside that inside that humidity so
again we will use a First Data and Main
dot humidity and we have to show a
humidity in the form of percentage so so
so that's why I'm writing a percentage
there so we got our humidity
43% and uh after that we have to use uh
we have to set a sunrise so for the
sunrise so if you will see there on the
data we are getting a sunrise and sunset
of that City so here we are getting some
values for the sunset and uh Sunrise so
we will convert these values in a time
so for that again we will use a date FNS
function that we have downloaded
previously uh so let's see how we can do
that so here we will write a format and
inside that format we'll use a format we
will use a from Unix time and we are
importing a uni time from date FNS
function and uh inside that we will pass
our date we will pass our data do City
do uh so first of all we have to pass a
sunrise
and and after that uh we have to pass a
format so format will be H do
mm and here we are getting error because
we have to pass some values so what I
will do I will copy that value from
there and because we must have to pass
some values so that's why we have to
pass it like that and we have to pass
this in the form of string so there it
means we are passing our sunrise data
there and in some case if we don't get
any Sunrise data or we are getting
undefined values so we are passing this
instead of
this and let's add another parameter so
we will do the same for Sunset so we
just have to add a sunset there and uh
after that uh let's add a wind
speed and for the wind speed so if you
will see there in the final output so we
are getting our wind speed in a
kilometer per hour but if you will check
that data and here let's check the First
Data do wind here we are getting our
speed in m/ second and we have to
convert this speed into a kilm per hour
so for that again we will create another
utility function so let's come to the
code again and uh go to the utils file
there and here we will write a convert
wind speed
dots and uh we will and we will create
this function so with the help of this
function this will accept speed speed in
me/ second and uh what this will give us
this will give us a speed in speed in
kilometer per hour and let's save this
and copy this function and uh use this
function on that place and let's also
import this function there
and inside that first of all we have to
use this and inside that function we
have to pass a First Data dot uh wind do
speed and if this is undefined so we
have to pass uh some sample data so I
will use this one and let's save this
and see the output so now you can see
that currently we not getting any error
in this page and everything is fine and
uh we got our UI like this now let's
create a UI for our forecast 7 days so
here what we will do for this one we
will create a separate component and
after that we will map this component
according to our data so first of all
let's create uh forecast weather detail
component so here we have already
created our file and now let's create
this component fully so on that
component firstly we have to use a
container tag there and ins inside that
we have another section and inside that
we have two sections so first section
will contain this weather detail I can
and these data and another section will
contain these data so let's create a
section tag
there and inside that let's pass a class
name and let's also give the class name
there so this will be the class name and
uh we have already applied a flex there
so we just have to pass a gap four
and in our first section firstly we have
another
Dave and inside that da we have a
weather icon component so let's import
our weather icon component there and on
that we have to pass our feather icon
props for this component so what props
we need first of all if you will see
there here we need a weather icon and
date and day and after that we need a
temperature and feels like temperature
and uh obviously minimum temperature
maximum temperature so we need all these
data and we also need all these props
that is visibility humidity wind
pressure so what we will do we will get
these props from our previous component
so let's see how we can do that so
firstly we have created a props for our
these data
that I have told you before like icon
date icon date day temperature all these
and now we need all these props also so
for that we will use a extend keyword
and which type we need we need these
weather details we are already exporting
these props from that place so I will
just copy it from there and uh come to
my weather forecast detail component and
I will just paste it there and let's
press control space and import so this
will import and extend these props so I
will use this on that
place and let's give this name a props
like that and what I will do I will pass
some I will pass some default values for
these props so what we have done for
this component that is weather details
we will do the same for this forecast
weather details so this will be
something like this and now first of all
let's pass our now let's pass our props
there so here we need a icon name and on
that icon name we will just simply pass
a weather
icon and uh after that uh and after that
we have a paragraph inside that
paragraph we have a date and after that
date uh another paragraph and inside
that graph we have a day but uh our day
will
be something small so I will give this
text SM like this so if you will see in
the final output So currently we have
just created this part now let's create
this UI so for that again uh use another
div and uh inside that div we will use a
class name and this will be the flx and
uh flx call and padding X will be four
and first of all we need a temperature
so here we will use a span tag to show
our temperature and obviously we need to
convert our temperature into Kelvin to
Celsius so that's why I'm using this
Kelvin to Celsius function there and now
we need our paragraph tag inside that
paragraph tag we need to we need to show
our Fields like temperature so this will
be something like this this will be text
extra small and space between these
fields likes and temperature will be 4
pixel so that's why I'm passing like
that and uh I'm passing also white space
no wrap so this will not breaks into two
lines and after that let's show the
description so for the description we
will just simply write description so
this is our description for our weather
data and now we have completed our this
uh left section
now let's now it's time to create a
right section so for our right section
again we will create a section tag there
and inside that we will use these class
names that is Overflow X Auto and flex
justify between Gap 4 padding X4 width
will be full padding right 10 and inside
that we will use our weather details
comp component so this is our weather
detailed component so let's copy this
one and import this component on that
place and now we need to pass all these
props all these props of this one so
here is a one trick like uh we can also
pass it by one by one like uh here we
can do like props do air pressure
something like that but uh here is
another trick what we can do we can just
simply write curly bracket there and
triple Dot and simply we can write props
and we can simply write props so this
will automatically get all of props on
this one with the help of this and uh
that's it for this component that is
forecast weather detail component and
let's save this and copy this component
and uh come to the main page and we need
this component on that place and here we
have to pass all these props that uh we
need there but before that we need to do
one thing that is uh if you will see on
our final data so on that object here we
are getting a 40 arrays so what we need
to do we need to make some logic and uh
we need a one data for every single day
and on that 40 data we are getting four
or five data for the same day so what we
will do we will create some logic and
with the help of that logic we will only
filter out a single data for every day
and store it in a separate array and
after that we will map that array so
let's see how we can do that so for that
we will use this logic and before that
here we are getting an error because I'm
using a set so if you are getting any
error while using a set keyword so you
have to go to the ts. config file and
here you have to write instead of es5
that is you have to write
es2015 and let's save this file and uh
now you can see that now we are not
getting any error regarding our set and
let's understand this logic So currently
what's going on there this is filtering
our data date wise so with the help of
this logic we are getting a unique dates
and after that we are mapping that
unique dates and from that unique dates
we are extracting the data here we are
filtering a daytime data like after 6
a.m. and uh before 6:00
p.m. so let's copy this array and uh we
need to map this on that place and uh
let me tell you one thing I have created
uh this logic from chat GTP means I know
what to do I have just explained the
chat GTP like I need to create some
variable in that way that uh this will
get the data in the DA for that this
will UniFi the data and uh give a single
data from every day something like that
and let's copy this data and uh now we
need to map it there so let's use a cly
bracket there and after that use a map
inside that map use Arrow function and
inside that Arrow function let's map
this component and first of all let's
pass a key so here firstly we have to
import this components so that's why we
are not getting a stion for our key so
now you can see that we are getting all
SS for our props so firstly let's pass a
key and uh inside that key before
passing the key let's pass uh D and I so
d means data and I means index so in the
key we will pass uh I and after that we
will pass our all of our props so I'm
just uh passing all of our props like
that so if you will see there I have
passed a description with the help of D
do weather and on that weather I'm
selecting a First Data and after that
I'm passing that description and for the
weather icon I'm just doing the same and
for the date what we have done
previously I'm just converting that date
in a proper string format but on that
time we need our date in in that format
so that's why I have written a dd. MM
likewise we are passing all of our props
that uh we have previously passed I
haven't done anything new there so
that's why I have just copied this code
from my previous project and paste it
there and now let's save this and uh see
the
output so now you can see that we got
our UI like this but uh there is
something wrong this is not in the
proper Center so let's go to the code
and see what is the issue so here on
that name we have to pass our class name
that is
flex Flex call and GAP will be one and
items Center and now you can see that we
got our data in a proper form and now
there is two things left when the user
will search so we have to apply a search
functionality and when the user will
click on that button so we need to show
the weather report for that current
location so first of all we will create
our search and after that we will create
this functionalities when the user will
click on that button so this will show
the weather data for that current
location so let's go to the code and uh
we have to go to the Navar component so
I will click on that Navar and now we
are inside the naar component and here
what we need to do if you can see there
on a final output so when I'm start
typing like Delhi so now you can see
that we are getting a su so firstly
let's uh implement this functionality so
for that we will create some use States
so first of all we need to create a
state for this value and on change so
here uh we will give this value name to
a city and set city state and we have to
also import our use state so we will
import our user state from react like
that and uh we have to also create our
error State like uh if we will go to the
final output and suppose if I am typing
something typing anything and uh this
place is not exist and when I'm trying
to press enter so we will get this error
like a location not
found so for that we will create a error
State like that and now we will create a
use state for our sessions that will
store our sessions and another state to
show our SS or not so this first state
will store a array of our like SS and uh
second state will store a like bulling
true or false our SS is open or not and
on that search value we have to pass a
city and uh for we have to also pass on
Sumit so so we will pass it later and we
have to also pass a on change and uh for
the on
change we will create another function
to handle input on change so we will
create uh this function there handle
input change and after that this
parenthesis curly bracket open and first
of all what we will do when user is
start typing and first of all this
function will be the async function
because uh on that on change we will get
a SS from our API so we have to make
this as a
async and here first of all when the
user will start typing on that input box
so we have to set a city so I will use a
set City there like that so this is the
set City and uh we have to pass that
value that we will get it from that
function and the type of that value will
be string so let's copy this one and uh
pass pass my function there and we will
use e and we will pass our function like
that and here we will pass our value
like e. Target do value like that and
here we will get our value so now we
have to pass our value like that there
and now on that place we have to check a
condition if our value do length is
greater than three then we have to fetch
our SS data so we will write it like
that like uh if is equals to or greater
than three so we will search for our SS
and on that if we will use a try catch
block and on that try we will uh fetch
our data so here first of all we will uh
write our uh create a variable like
const response and uh this will be await
because here we are using a async and a
wait means if this operation will take
some time so so that's why we are using
a wait so it means if this will take a
time so this will wait and uh after that
here we will use xos to fetch our data
xos doget and now on that place here we
will pass our API and uh we are getting
this value from there value on the place
of value we are passing a place like
whatever the user will type so this will
search for that location and now we have
to pass the API key so what I will do on
top of that function I will store that
API key in that variable and with the
help of this process. env. next public
weather Key and I have shown you before
from where we are getting this uh
process. env. next public weather key so
we have to go to that file that is uh
there on my left hand side this is env.
loal and here I have defined my API key
now inside that try block let's create
another variable that is called sus and
this will be equal to the response do
data
do list do
map and uh after that uh here we will
use Arrow function and for now I'm just
using a item and this will be the type
of any now what we need to do we need to
store a name of that place that will
match so here I will write a item do
name so this will map over there and
store all of our Su in a s variable now
we will use a set suggestions there and
inside that set suggestions we will pass
our suggestions and here we will set our
error to null if everything is okay so
we will set our error is to empty and
after that here we will also uh open our
s box so for for that here I will write
a set so SS that is true and inside that
our catch block what uh we will do we
will set our SS to a empty array and we
will also hide our s box or S container
so for that again we will write like set
s
SS and here we will set it false and now
comes to the else part so here I will WR
uh else and inside that else we have to
do the same that uh what we have done
for our catch block so I will copy it
from there and uh paste it there and we
are using a user State there so we have
to also make this component as a use
client so here we will write a use
client on top of our
file and now we will come on the UI and
on the UI we have to show our session
so what I will do for the SS I will
create another component so I will write
a function there and this will be the s
box and here we will use a UL tag and
inside that uh UL tag we have our
suggestions so for the suggestions I
will use a Alli tag so first of all
let's style our uh U tag so for U tag we
will use a margin bottom of four B white
absolute
border or top 44 pixel left zero so here
we are using absolute so we will use our
session box there on that place so here
we will use a class name and uh we will
pass a relative class name there so this
s box will be relative to that container
so that's why we are passing that like
uh top 44 pixel and
left zero so this will Define the
position of our session box and after
that we are passing our simply border
gray 300 rounded MD and minimum height
will be 200 pixel and flex and flex call
Gap one padding y padding y
two and now let's also give the styling
for our Alli so for the lii we will use
a cursor pointer and padding will be one
and this will be some rounded this will
be the rounded of 4 pixel and on H this
background color will be PG gray
200 and now let's create a props for our
s component so these are the props of
our s box component first one is
associations so with the help of this we
will toggle our s box and uh with in
that SS this will contain the array of
our
SS and uh with the help of handle s
click click so when the user will click
on that uh button like if I will search
for any
country so now we got our sessions and
if I will click on that button so here
on that place we are applying a handle
session click and after that if we are
getting any error so we will also pass
that error with the help of that prop so
now let's use empty fragment and wrap up
our code with with that empty fragment
and here we will use uh some conditions
to show our SS
conditionally so firstly so firstly we
have to write sociations is true or not
and after that we have to check the
length is greater than one or not so for
that here we will write
uh cations do length is greater than one
or otherwise if our error is true so so
again we will show our s box because we
have to show a error on our s
box and we will again wrap up our code
like that and here again we will use a
end operator and on that end operator if
this condition is true so now we have to
show this code and if I will format so
this will look like this and now what we
need to do inside that uh UL tag if our
error is true so here we will use a
curly bracket and we will write error
and end operator and
sus do length is less than one it means
our s is zero or we are not getting any
SS and end operator so what we need to
do so we have to show this Ali and this
Ali will contain a error and here I have
also passed a text red 500 and padding
one and inside that we are passing our
error and uh after that we will pass our
s with the help of map so again use a
curly bracket and suggestions. map
inside that Arrow
function and uh inside that Arrow
function we have our lii and obviously
this will contain a key
and first parameter will be D and second
will be
I so let's take this item and on that
key let's pass a I so I means
index and inside that Ali we have to
pass our item uh we can also say that
location name or place name and let's
save this code and uh and when the user
will click on that particular SS so we
have to use uh on click there and and on
that on click we have to pass our handle
s click so we will use Arrow function
there because we have to also pass our
icon so first of all let's take a handle
s click and inside that uh we have to
pass our item like that and we are
getting our item from
there and let's save this and on that s
box we have to pass all of our
props so here we can pass our props so
here you can see that for the
error City and S and so SS I have
already created a user state so we can
simply pass it but uh for the handle SS
I haven't created any function so let's
just create a function for handle s
click so this is our handle s click
function so this function will accept a
value or string so what we will do when
the user will click on that uh handle
click but button or we can say that uh
particular s so we will set that our
city to that value so that's why we are
using that set City that value and after
that we will hide our s so that's why we
are passing this set Association is
false and there is a one trick uh that I
have that I'm using lots of time like uh
we can simply also pass our data like
error equals to
error or like handle s equals to like uh
copy this and paste it like that we can
also pass our data like this but here's
another trick that we can do just simply
copy all these data and uh put a double
curly bracket there and use a spread
operator there and paste your props
there so now you can see that we are not
getting any complaints or error there
and now let's create a function for our
onsubmit so we will create a function
that is handle submit search so I will
just write here function handle submit
search and inside that function this
will accept a parameter like e what will
be the type of e so you already know
what is the type of e like uh if I will
go there and simply type and simply
write my function with the help of using
Arrow function and when I will H over
that so now you can see that I got the
type for that uh e so I will copy that
type from there and paste it on that
place and first of all when the user
will submit so what we need to do first
of all see there when I will click on
that so this is our current application
so when I'm clicking on that one so now
you can see that our whole page is
refreshing so we have to avoid to
refresh our page so for that here we
will use a e do prevent default so with
the help of this this we can prevent our
page from refreshing so I will copy this
function from there and use my function
on that on submit like that and let's
save our code and uh when I will click
on that so I'm clicking and pressing the
enter but my page is not
refreshing and let's write a further
code there so here we will write a
condition if our suggestions do length
is is equals to equals to
Zer so it means uh we are not getting
any sus so what we need to do on that
condition and I have clicked on that
button so we have to show a error state
so here I will write a set error and on
that set error we have to pass like
location not found it means on the else
condition means our soltion length is
greater than zero so here uh we will
remove remove our error so for that here
first of all we will set our error like
uh set error and our error will be
empty and uh after that we will set our
city and here we will also set our like
set suggestions is false and uh when I
will save my code and uh when I'm
searching anything so now you can see
that I'm getting a proper sessions and
when I will click on that one so my
search
box is working perfectly fine but see
there when I'm clicking on that one so
this is not working perfectly that uh we
want so here what we need to do whatever
the city name we are getting here we
need to pass it from our uh this level
to page level so if you will see on the
code so if I will come so let's firstly
close all the files and uh let's firstly
come to the
page and on that page page here we need
to change our city So currently I'm just
passing a Pune but here we need our city
whatever we are getting on that navbar
search so for that we have to do
something like we are setting our city
from our naar component this will
somehow we have to get our city on our
page and after that uh if our city if
our city is changed so this API or data
will again call and after that we will
get our data so for that we have to use
a global state so for that we will use a
jotai so let's see how we can use a
jotai global State Management so let's
go to the browser and search for jotai
and uh here you will get the official
website of jotai so this is the global
State Management
solution so first of all let's install a
jotai so let's copy this npm code and uh
and come to your code and install the ji
like that and after that in your app
folder let's create a new file that is
called
atom. TS so here we will create our
atoms or we can also say that here we
will create our state and after that uh
we will Import in this file and in our
navare file so on our atom file there is
a main State and we are just import it
uh into a page and Nar so this will work
so let's see how we can do that so first
of all we have to create a place atom so
what we will do we will use a export
keyword and here we have to create a
variable so I will just simply give that
const and uh variable name that is place
atem so currently we need a atom for our
place or location so that's why I have
given this name as a place atem and
let's also import our atom so we need to
import our Atom from jotai and uh here
like we here like we use a use state so
we have to pass some default values So
currently I'm just passing a default
place that is Republic of
India and now what we need to do let's
copy this place atem and uh come on the
navbar component and after that here
what we will do we will exactly use it
like we use a US state here I will just
simply create a US state snpp it and uh
after that on the place of second we
have to use our place atom and on the
place of use State we have to use a use
Atom from zai and now we can give any
name that we want but uh we have to give
a name like we give as a user state name
so we can give any name but here we need
a place so I will give this place
and here uh you need to give a set
place like that and now what we need to
do we need to set our place when the
user will click on that submit button or
like enter button so we need to pass our
set place there and here we need to set
our place so our place is City so this
is the city and when the user will click
on that button
or this button So currently I'm getting
error so let's save our file because I
haven't saved my ATM file so that's why
we are getting error so now our error is
gone so I'm talking about this city when
the user will click on that button so
what this will do this will store that
uh City on that variable now we are
using this as a global state so what I
will do I will just simply copy this one
and come to my page and paste it there
like that and uh we can give this any
name that we want this uh doesn't matter
the main thing is that this value should
be same that uh we are giving there so
we have to firstly import this one and
after that we have to import use atem
from
chai and this is coming from that atem
from there and uh now we have to do it
like uh we do for like we do as a for
user state so we need this place on that
uh pun so here uh we will use a curly
bracket and dollar symbol and we will
pass our place like that and uh when I
will save my code and see the output so
let's refresh and search for like Del
and click on that one and search so now
you can see that this is not working so
this is not working because
when any data will change so we have to
refetch that data so for that on that uh
use Query we are getting another
parameter or prop that is called
refetch and we have to call that refetch
when anything will change so for that we
will use a use effect so let's write a
snipp it for our use effect like this
and let's also import our use effect so
let's copy this one and uh write here
import use effect from react like that
and after that we have to pass this
refetch function there and here on that
place we have to pass a
parameter so the parameter is place when
our place state will change so we have
to refetch our data and here we have to
also pass a second parameter like when
our refetch will change so we have to
also refetch that data and let's save
this one and uh let's search for Val and
click on that so our data is changed
like if I will search for so now you can
see that currently here we are getting
13° temperature and let's search for my
location that is Merit so let's click on
that and click on that one so now you
can see that our data is changed but
currently we are not getting any loading
State and uh our name is not also
changing on that place so first of all
let's change the name and add a loading
state so to change the name on our Nar
we will pass our
name from there so let's go to the Nar
component and here let's create uh one
prop that is called location and let's
import our location there and uh now
what we need to do here I have written
somewhere India so in the place of India
we will uh write it location and again
we will go to the page and on that page
we have a prop of location and on that
location we will use a data do City do
name and let's save this and now you can
see that we are getting our city name
there uh let's search for any other city
like uh if I will search for Pune before
that see the current temperature for
merit and let's click on that button so
now you can see that our data is changed
and we are getting currently 18°
temperature and here name is also
changed but uh the main problem is that
we are not getting any loading state so
for that again we will create another
state and this state will be also the
global state so for that again come to
the atom file and here we are creating a
loading City atom and by default our
loading will be false so let's copy this
loading State loading City atom and uh
come to the name bar and like we have
done for this place item we will do the
same for our loading so here in the
place of place item we have to pass a
loading item and let's import this one
and on the place we don't need a first
parameter so we just write it like that
and uh for the loading State we also
don't need a loading there we just need
to set a loading from that place so I
will just write it like that and uh for
this on the place of set place I will
give this as a set loading like this and
here we are getting error because these
two are same
so let's give this a place and now this
is different so that's is fine and now
we have to handle our loading state so
whenever the user will click on that
handle submit button handle submit
button so we have to control our set
loading so first of all when the user
will click on our button so we have to
set our loading will be true and uh when
we are inside that condition like uh our
length is equals to zero our s length
equals to zero so we will just simply
make it false like that and on that else
condition we will also make our loading
will be false it means our like data is
fed and we have to make it false and
what we need to do we need to perform
these three operations after like5
second so that we can see a loading
State because our data is uh getting
like too fast so that's why we are not
getting any loading state so for that we
will use use a set
timeout and inside that set timeout we
will pass our uh these three parameters
and here we have to pass our time so I
will pass it like 500 so 500 means. 5
Second and uh let's save this and uh we
have to also use this variable in our
page so I've copied from there and let's
use it on that place so let's also
import our loading City atem on our
page and if you will see on our final
output when I'm clicking on that so we
are getting a skeleton loading
components so we have to also create
this one so let's come to the code again
and uh here what I have done I have uh
just simply copy all of my code from
there from Main and uh go to the chat
GTP and uh I have told the chat GTP to
create a skeleton loading component for
me and here now you can see that what
output I'm getting so this is the
function that uh chat GTP gave me I have
just told him that uh I need to use a
animate pulse because I already knew
about the animate pulse so with the help
of that animate pulse we are getting our
div in the form of like a
pulse and uh now we will use this
skeleton component in as a conditionally
so what we will do here uh we will use
empty fragments and on that empty
fragment we will pass this one and uh if
our loading city is true like that so we
have to write it like a loading City
there and we don't need a set loading on
that place so this will be like
this and now if our uh loading is true
so so we have to show this weather
skeleton loading component so I will
copy it from there and paste it uh like
that and if our loading will true so
this will show our loading component
otherwise this will show our main
data so I have to put a c bracket there
and here I have to put a columns now our
error is gone and let's see the final
output and if I will search for any data
like um Delhi and click on that so this
is our main app that we are currently
working on and now you can see that we
are getting a proper loading skeleton
component and uh now this is looking
good and on that place we are also
getting a proper name for our location
now only one thing is left or not one
thing that is there's two things is left
firstly uh let's create a function for
our like when a user will click on that
button so we will get our current
location so let's go to the code and go
to the Nar and uh here we have already
created a icon for our current location
so first of all let's add a title like
your current location so what is mean by
the title so when anyone will hover over
that so you can see that we are getting
a title like your current location
and now we have to create a function
like uh when anyone click on that uh
function when anyone click on that
button so you have to show a current
location so in that case we will give
that function name that is handle
current location and uh let's create
current location function on that place
and on that handled current location
function first of all we'll check the
condition like if Navigator do
geolocation is true then then uh we have
to use a navigator do geolocation do get
current position and here inside that we
will use a async function so here I will
write async or after that Arrow function
and inside that parameter we will use a
position so this will gives us a
position so let's give the any name so I
want to give a position name and inside
that let's ract our longitude and
longitude so for that here we will write
a const curly bracket and from where we
have to extract so we have to extract
from position this will be equal to
position dot C and what we need to
extract we need to extract uh latitude
and longitude and after that we have to
use a try and catch block so inside that
try we have to set our uh like when I'm
clicking on that button the we need to
set our loading is true so for that we
will write like set loading city is true
now we have to fetch our uh data with
the help of longitude and longitude so
for that we have to write our API in
that form like weather or question mark
and after that we have to use a let
parameter in and this will be equal to
that longitude and after that use end
and and uh pass a l and Lawn it means we
are passing a longitude and after that
pass your API key like that and here
after that again we will use a set
timeout and we will make our loading
false and uh on that set place that
before we are setting our place with the
help of that handle submit before that
we are setting our place with the help
of that handle sessions on click so now
we need to set our place and we are
getting our place name from our this
data and on that cat block if we are
getting any issue so we will make our uh
set loading state to the false and let's
save this one and see the output so when
I will click on that button so this will
ask me the permissions to allow your
location for the first time so I will
allow this one and now this is searching
for my location and and uh this is my
current location and now we I'm getting
the current location data now again
let's click on that Delhi so so search
for Delhi and now if I will again click
on that uh location current location so
now you can see that I got my current
location there now we have completed our
search box and this current location but
uh one thing is left like if I will go
to the Mobile screen so now you can see
that our Navar is not responsive
so let's make our Navar responsive so
for that let's come to the code again
and here on that da we will hide it on
mobile and uh show on MD screen so for
that we will use a class name that is
hidden so by default this will be hidden
on Mobile screen and this day will show
on MD screen and uh after that here we
will use uh this empty
fragments like that and after that nav
we will use this again same da there so
I will just copy it from there and paste
it there but uh here we have to change
some conditions and we have to also
create a parent uh container for this da
so for that I will create another
section and uh wrap up this code with
this section and this section will
contain the maximum width of 7 XEL and
padding X will be three and on the
mobile screens this will show but on the
MD screen this will be hidden and uh we
don't need this code like hidden or MD
on that place and now everything is fine
there so let's save this and now you can
see that on mobile our UI will look like
this one and uh let's see on a proper
mobile So currently we are checking our
UI in like iPhone
XR and uh now if we will see on uh
different screens so this will look like
this so our application is fully
completed and uh this is fully
responsive so that's it now our weather
app is fully
completed so don't forget to like share
and uh if you are new to my channel so
don't forget to subscribe my channel
because I upload videos regarding next
year's Tailwind CSS and typ script until
then I will see you in next
one